so bitcoin only has users it doesn't
have any admins there's nobody with a
master key
and um
we've you know this this is kind of the
um
simple way of thinking about it which is
10 years of this thing operating without
anybody being in charge and with
everybody who tried to change the
consensus parameters the most important
parameters of the network everybody who
tried to change these
ended up basically failing and bitcoin
has maintained its consensus parameters
to the point where you could run it
according to the same code that was
available in 2009 and you could still
make it interoperable with the current
chain and that's
that's something that is unique about
bitcoin which is that it is the coin
that you know i like to call it the
immaculate conception somebody uh made
these coins anybody could have mined the
coins from the first day you know they
announced the
currency and they said i'm going to
start running it on this day and anybody
could have joined and since then
everybody who got bitcoin got bitcoin at
the market price or because they mined
it and expended resources which roughly
cost them close to what the market price
was so there are no insiders in bitcoin
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to have
with me dr sevadine amus
he's an independent economist as well as
a leading researcher communicator and
educator in the field of bitcoin he
obtained his phd at columbia university
dr safidine is the author of the bitcoin
standard which was published in 2018
and the newly released fiat standard
he has advised corporations on bitcoin
strategy helping many investors perform
their due diligence on bitcoin
dr amos teaches courses on the economics
of bitcoin and economics in the austrian
school tradition
in his online learning platform
safedean.com
and also hosts the bitcoin standard
podcast thanks very much for agreeing to
talk to me today and i'm looking forward
to learning a lot about things i know
very little about today
so um
tell us maybe to begin with about
your books let's start with the bitcoin
standard and and then move to the fiat
standard so the bitcoin standard
yeah well first of all thank you very
much for having me on it's a true
pleasure to be talking to you um i
published the bitcoin standard in 2018
and um it was a book that tried to
explain the economics of bitcoin why
bitcoin functions why it functions the
way it does and what are the um
implications that you would expect from
the continued growth of bitcoin uh in
the future and so um i analyzed it from
the perspective of the austrian school
relying on the work of economists like
karl menger and ludwig von mises and
marty rothbard and joe salerno and
friedrich hayek and
i think
the key insight that i well there were
several key insights but one of the most
important ones in the book is that
um bitcoin is the hardest money that has
ever been invented because
um we've essentially thrown away
the the algorithm for making bitcoin
work
has been set at uh producing a certain
number of bitcoin over time that's going
to end at 21 million and there's no way
of making more bitcoins and i think
after 12 years of bitcoin operating we
can pretty confidently say
there's not going to be more than 21
million bitcoin and so that makes
bitcoin truly unique as a monetary asset
because it is the hardest monetary asset
that we've ever found
um there's no
let me ask you a question about that so
why is it important that that limit
exists
and what do you mean by hardest currency
compared to other currencies yeah so the
hardness here refers to the uh
difficulty of making more currency units
to add on to the existing supply
and i think this is a big deal and
essentially the first four chapters of
my book focus on explaining why this is
such a big deal because if you look
historically at money you find that
money has been a
contest of survival of the hardest
people are always looking for the
hardest money available and the ones who
manage to find the hardest money manage
to store their wealth in it successfully
whereas the ones who use an easy money
will witness their wealth dissipate so
people will learn but even if they don't
learn you know the market will brutally
teach them the lesson by
discounting and reducing the wealth of
the people who put in the easy money so
the end result is that more and more
wealth will be concentrated in the
harder money and that's why historically
when societies that had hard their money
came into contact with societies that
had easier money
they the ones with the hard money were
able to essentially
buy up a lot of the resources of the
easy money societies because they could
continue to make more of their money and
therefore devalue the money and increase
the supply of it and there are many
examples in my book about this
seashells and glass beads and limestones
all were used as money when
industry made them scarce in certain
times and places but then when modern
technology came and allowed for an
increase in their supply their value was
declining and then in the 19th century
we see this happen between gold and
silver too the price of gold and silver
i used to oscillate around 15 ounces of
silver
per 1 ounce of gold and in 150 years
it's now or somewhere around 100
it's gotten to around 120 recently
so the price of silver has been
declining next to gold and i think that
can be explained by the fact that gold
is harder the supply of silver is being
increased at a faster rate and
there was utility in the use of silver
when money was physical but then with
the
creation of essentially um
financial instruments that were backed
by gold you could use silver you could
use gold payments for small amounts of
payments as well as large amounts of
payments so that kind of obsoleted the
role of silver and so everybody went
with the harder money and then the
harder money appreciated and the easier
money continued to lose its monetary
status okay so let me let me see if i if
i've got this straight so money is an
abstract store of value
and
you always want it to represent
value as such so something like the
exchange of labor or the exchange of
efficiency something like that and you
can correct me if i'm wrong there
you have to use something to represent
that abstraction and the problem with
that is that there will be people who
have control over the representation
rather than contributing to the value
and those could be politicians who could
print money or they could be people who
well who find silver or who find gold or
who mine it and so forth so anything
that can be produced that's a
representation
is subject to devaluation if the
production becomes more efficient and
anything that's
producible
like a paper money can be uh
toyed with by those who have control
over its distribution and so your
argument essentially and the bitcoin
argument in general is well here's
something that we will never get more of
no matter what we do so i'd like to know
why i should believe that
and the next thing i'd like to know
about that maybe is well why why bitcoin
and not 200 alternative cryptocurrencies
like so bitcoin can't be produced but
crypto currencies can be and so why
isn't that an indication of the softness
of cryptocurrency bitcoin included
yeah well these are great questions so i
think um initially yeah you're
absolutely spot on um it's
it's exactly that that whatever gets
chosen is money it holds value because
it has value on the market but as soon
as it starts getting chosen as money it
gets into what i call the easy money
trap which is
the people who can make more of it will
try and make more of it people will find
a way and they will make more of it and
so the things that have ended up being
used as money were always the thing that
resisted that the most things that are
the hardest and so gold did an excellent
job with that because gold's chemistry
naturally gives it that property because
gold is indestructible so because we've
been accumulating gold
production over thousands of years no
matter how much gold we produce this
year it's still going to be a tiny
fraction of all of the stuff that we've
accumulated over the last 5 000 years
and so every year the gold supply
increases by around one and a half
percent and that's why i beat everything
out so the hardest thing ends up winning
you know whether people consciously
realize that that is the case or just
because of the realities of supply and
demand every year we're making five
percent or 20 or 30 percent more silver
and maybe 100 more copper and larger
quantities of all other commodities on
the market but we're only making one and
a half or two percent gold so over time
gold holds on to its value and over time
that ends up being the best store of
value so
um gold resisted that and then
gold failed for issues we could talk
about when we talk about the fiat
standard but then bitcoin offers us this
a possibility again which is that nobody
can uh break this uh algorithm and i
must say this is really the um
the the reasonable skepticism about
bitcoin is that yeah well you know it's
just a line of code and then anybody can
change it it's a line of code you know
we can change the lines of code all the
time somebody can get under the hood and
change the code
and it takes a lot of time to be able to
understand why this is not exactly the
case and i try and make that case in my
book extensively in the latter chapters
of the book
um but if i were to summarize it i would
say this
with bitcoin what we had was that the um
the the person who created the quote
he put it out there he was anonymous he
uh worked on it for about a year or two
and then he disappeared and uh that was
it
there was nobody in charge since then
it's now been more than 10 years that
he's been disappeared and there's not
been anybody in charge of the project
and what we've only had are users so
bitcoin only has users it doesn't have
any admins there's nobody with a master
key
and um
we've you know this this is kind of the
um
simple way of thinking about it which is
10 years of this thing operating without
anybody being in charge and with
everybody who tried to change the
consensus parameters the most important
parameters of the network everybody who
tried to change these
ended up basically failing and bitcoin
has maintained its consensus parameters
to the point where you could run it
according to the same code that was
available in 2009 and you could still
make it interoperable with the current
chain and that's that's something that
is unique about bitcoin which is that it
is the coin that you know i like to call
it the immaculate conception somebody uh
made these coins anybody could have
mined the coins from the first day you
know they announced the currency and
they said i'm going to start running it
on this uh
day and anybody could have joined and
since then everybody who got bitcoin got
bitcoin at the market price or because
they mined it and expended resources
which
roughly cost them close to what the
market price was so there are no
insiders in bitcoin and bitcoin has
operated this way for 12 years now
and um
this is kind of the sociological
explanations for it now to get more
technical in terms of the explanations
basically bitcoin is a distributed
network and so
anybody can run the code on their own
computer and the network functions
according to the consensus parameters
that everybody agrees upon
okay so i i don't know what those are
the consensus parameters can you tell me
what those are
what does that mean
basically the the main and most
important rules according to which the
network runs from the beginning and
one of them perhaps the most important
constitution
yes it's like the constitution and
perhaps the most important one is the
number of coins that are generated
so we have a very strict and clear
schedule of how many coins are going to
be produced every day essentially in
perpetuity and um
if you abide by these consensus rules
then your computer can be in sync with
the rest of the network and you're in
consensus with the network and you can
and you can buy and sell coins and you
can transact coins on the network but if
you try and break those consensus
parameters you leave the coin
so
the miracle of bitcoin in a sense is
that it has managed to maintain these
important consensus parameters for 12
years now and it continues to get
increasingly more ossified every day
bitcoin is the most conservative thing
in human history probably there's not
going to be
it just continues to get harder and
harder to change the constitution of
bitcoin and nobody's been able to do it
in 12 years so
that's kind of the um
superficial or
broad picture explanation of those
things but you could also get into the
software itself
you know it's a distributed network so
everybody needs to be in consensus with
the network
and then
if you end up breaking the rules if you
end up trying to change the rules which
a lot of people have tried to do
all that you will do is that you will
end up with another bitcoin that is out
there competing on the market with the
original bitcoin but you've got a lot
less liquidity and you've got a lot less
ability to compete and we've seen many
people try and do that and all that has
happened is that their coins have
you know continued to change their
consensus parameters because once you
break
the you know once you break your duck
once then it just becomes much easier to
do it and they
devolved into
civil strife between participants on the
network and of course they lost economic
value and the value of the network has
essentially dissipated close to zero
so
uh bitcoin continues to get stronger
because it continues to demonstrate that
it can do those few very simple
technological tasks and it can do them
reliably and it can do them according to
the same rules that it has been doing
them for 12 years that's kind of the
value proposition it's immutable it's
decentralized
and the money supply is fixed so that's
kind of a big deal if you put all of
these all together
right and so
it's hard for anyone to make a bitcoin
substitute that can catch up to it
because it's established a kind of
primacy given its
track history of reliability and its
widespread distribution that's part of
the argument for its primacy
yes but i think it's more than that it's
not just you know coca-cola and pepsi
catching up to one another or mcdonald's
and burger king there is a fundamental
issue here which is that what you would
want the most in this kind of digital
currency because after all this is all
numbers and ones and zeros and
programmers can change it and so
if your programmers can change the
consensus parameters of the network
which basically all the other digital
currencies can do at will you know the
other digital currencies they have these
hard forks which change the consensus
parameters quite frequently
and particularly the successful ones
because the way that you know they
managed to get successful was
essentially through active management
and so they're more like companies
rather than uh private protocols and the
the key thing is as you said there is a
first mover advantage but there's also
the problem of the immaculate conception
you know if you make a new bitcoin
that's going to start from scratch
um you break consensus parameters or you
start by imposing new consensus
parameters you're already you know not
starting with that immaculate conception
you're already starting with the idea
that there's somebody in charge and so
there's now it's not 200 coins there's
about 10 000 coins and if you've heard
about any of them other than bitcoin
it's because there's a small group of
people that have been behind them and so
uh that
as far as i'm concerned makes it um
highly unlikely that they would have a
monetary role because at the end of the
day you know what you appreciate about
bitcoin what makes me pay attention to
bitcoin is that it is neutral money that
nobody can control so you can see
two banks in two different countries
um use bitcoin because that means they
don't need to resort to their own legal
system and their own central banks and
their own regulators in order to carry
out this transaction because bitcoin is
just neutral they know you know you you
it's it's like the an engine you know
you click the right buttons and then the
right smoke comes out and it does the
right uh transaction that you want
okay so i'm going to recapitulate that
uh for a moment so because there's
something in there too that's that's
quite difficult to
grasp quite difficult to believe apart
from the fact that the
the technical aspects are rather
impenetrable for an outsider um
this the way bitcoin came about
seems it seems like a story that's
virtually impossible to believe you you
can't you can't you couldn't make it up
right so this un known engineer satoshi
anonymous
created this
came up with this idea that no one else
had ever had
implemented it online
anonymized it and then vanished
essentially without a trace i mean how
much do people know about him are are we
sure he's who invented it and what the
hell was he up to and why did this
happen and why should an outsider
believe any of this because it does seem
like the plot of a bad science fiction
novel
the i i will confess that i i did used
to think about this in similar terms but
i'll say this you know you use the wheel
every day but you don't know who
invented the wheel and uh we use a lot
of things every day that uh you you
don't use them because you trust the guy
who made them you use them because they
have a proven track record you know
you've spent your life seeing wheels
working and so you're willing to trust a
wheel next time you get into a car
so um i think you know that's ultimately
what um
in a sense it's kind of bad press for
bitcoin but like
a lot of things about bitcoin it
actually ends up being illustrating its
strength yes this thing has a story that
you know
a pr person would tell you just don't
bother you know start doing something
else with your life rather than try and
sell this thing
and
it doesn't need anybody to sell it
that's kind of the point it doesn't have
a story it doesn't have a pr person
and the fact that it has this kind of
ugly story where this person just came
in and then disappeared and who knows
what happened nobody really knows you
know maybe he died maybe he um has other
things to keep him busy um maybe he's
incapacitated in some way but ultimately
it doesn't matter because even if he
were to come back today he has no
ability to control the network any more
than you and i can control it you know
he can control the code that he runs on
his computer but at this point the
project has worked 10 years without him
so there's no reason why anybody in
bitcoin is going to defer to his
judgment um if he were to come back but
besides this you know i think the the
key point is that it works regardless of
whether this person is part of it or not
okay so i'm
fair enough i i understand that so
advantages of bitcoin you contrasted oh
yeah a couple of questions advantages of
bitcoin over
fiat currency and both and that needs to
be defined fiat currency and then i i'm
also curious as an outsider
you're
an advocate i suppose of the austrian
school of economics
and there are a variety of economic
schools and maybe you could briefly for
everyone who's listening outline the
competing schools and what the different
propositions are and why there are
competing schools and why you chose the
austrian school
okay um
i'll uh i'll say this i think the main
the main split is between the austrians
and
everybody else as far as i'm concerned
when it comes to the main
most important questions
because the austrians come at the
question from
a different starting point which is that
value is subjective
economic value is subjective and that
then leads to a whole different
intellectual path with different
methodologies and different conclusions
from what you get from essentially
everybody within the
mainstream and when i say the mainstream
you know that includes um
neoclassical economists um chicago
school economist to some extent
keynesian economists and all other
different players and even marxist
economists because
on the main and big questions i think
the austrians stand
on a completely different ground which
is value is subjective so therefore
um
economic calculation is something that
is done at an individual level and it is
something that cannot be
done objectively by a centralized
authority um which is the kind of
physics envy that has plagued mainstream
economics throughout the 20th century so
this leads to a difference in
methodology leads to a difference in
conclusions which is
if once you understand that value is
subjective you realize the best person
who's able to achieve the important
values that
matter to them is the person themselves
and so you
you're more likely to be sympathetic to
ideas of that give individuals more
autonomy over their own life in economic
terms whereas from the other schools
it's a question of what is the optimum
policy and what kind of policy should um
government be using so
you know the entire the questioning of
the entire premise of the need for
economic policy and for the need of
economic management by the government is
one important difference so if you're if
you're working within the parameters of
the austrian economic school does that
tilt you so that tilts you more towards
appreciation of
non-centrally controlled distributed
networks and
and and the emphasis on the individual
actor that's that's
yes and to the mainstream economist this
is you know uh irredeemably ideological
and uh unscientific
but you know to the australian
what's the rationale for that though
because it seems precisely the opposite
i mean if you're if the because it seems
to me but that that's more grounded in a
kind of humility there's no way of of
determining once and for all what the
best thing is for the most people so
what we should try to do is establish um
institutions that distribute decision
making in as
what would in is an uncontrolled manner
as possible i suppose so so that's like
a rat in some sense that's is that a
radically free market approach that is
applied to all sorts of institutions and
and the fundamental issue there is the
decentralization of decision-making
power absolutely and this is what you
know from the mainstream perspective
appears to be um
ridiculous because in their mind you
know the job of the economist is to
figure out how the government can fix
the economy you know get rid of
unemployment and
eliminate uh wage disparities and get
rid of inequality and all these other uh
buzzwords that
appear to be you know profound economic
scientific thinking when really it's
just politics masquerading as um science
um so
and then so how would a mainstream
economist re react to that kind of
statement if you were playing devil's
advocate to to help me understand how
they would criticize what what they'd
say is uh i think uh what they'd say is
the austrian school made important
contributions up until the first world
war
to marginal analysis but then the field
advanced mathematically you know with
the improvement in mathematical
techniques that happened around the
world and with the advancement of
computers
there became so much more room for the
application of mathematical and
quantitative methods into economics and
the austrian school failed to keep up
with that and so they're still stuck in
the past writing essays shouting at the
clouds
not making much sense whereas you know
the mainstream has moved on to this
scientific management which is you know
once you scratch under the surface you
realize there's very few differences
between uh modern macroeconomist
scientific management and um
socialist economists and soviet
economists and their conception of
central planning it's uh in fact you
know one interesting anecdote paul
samuelson literally wrote the textbook
on economics in post-world war ii
america and the world
and his uh principles of economics
textbook which first came out in the 40s
or 50s i don't remember when was the
first edition and it continued to come
out until his death about 10 15 years
ago
up until the 1989 edition
the book had continuously when
discussing the soviet economy the book
had continuously said the soviet economy
will likely outperform the
u.s economy and it will overtake the us
economy within the next few years and
there's a paper that's done that goes
through all of these different editions
and as
samuelson continues to move the
goalposts you know they were supposed to
overtake the us in 68 but then by the
you know 65 edition they're supposed to
take the us in 75 now and then new
edition comes along and i don't remember
the exact dates but you know they kept
on kicking the cam downward
down the road while continuously you
know not challenging the
essential idea which is that central
planning of the economy works and the
soviet union is going to do a better job
than the u.s
but
their defense against central planning
of the economy is that it flies in the
face of democratic control of society
and we wouldn't want to infringe on
people's freedoms so for mainstream
economists
the problem with soviet economic
planning was that it necessitated you
know breaking a few eggs and putting a
few million people in gulags and that's
why we don't want it but it would work
and it would give us more gdp
and so this continued to be published in
paul samuelson's textbooks up until 1989
or 1990 or something like that you know
students were studying this in class as
the soviet union was collapsing and of
course you know this is fiat academia
fiat world um the next year they just
take that section out and they continue
to print the textbooks that continue to
teach kids in universities around the
world today that you know this is how
economics works economics is about
simply were you were you trained at
colombia as a classical economist
yeah i took the foundational course for
economics at columbia yeah
so my phd was in sustainable development
it wasn't entirely economics but we took
the foundational courses of economics
basically
so why did you become a deviant from
that let's say what what what was your
intellectual journey and i'm i'm very
curious about that
uh
well um
so my undergraduate background was in
mechanical engineering of all things
and in my phd it was in sustainable
development and we were supposed to
study the issues of you know energy and
society and economics and um approaches
from multi-disciplinary perspectives so
my engineering background and then my
new knowledge in economics
gave me that kind of what kayak calls
the fatal conceit of i'm just going to
pick a
topic in um
in energy economics in en energy and
engineering economics and you know study
it with the big brains of a columbia phd
and then figure out what needs to be
done basically
and then you know you can maintain these
illusions until you actually start
digging into the spreadsheets and then
you start trying to actually
mathematically model the complex world
outside and put it on a spreadsheet on
your computer and then you start
realizing just how absurd
these things are you know the yeah well
you'd think if you could do that then
you could put the stock market on a
spreadsheet and run your economic
wizardry and
gather all the money in the world with
your capability to model the economic
system and predict and yet no one can do
that
so
so and now let me
what one more comment about that i mean
i see
that danger of that fatal conceit
lurking
underneath all the discussions of
climate change
does that seem like a reasonable
proposition to you because it's a
justification for central planning
masquerading as a masquerading as well
we we have to save the planet we know
what's wrong with it and we know how to
fix it and our solutions are going to
work and they're not going to produce
produce unintended consequences and it's
so dire that you need to leave us alone
while we do this and we know better than
you do
exactly and that's that's exactly how i
essentially went off the reservation
because you know the topic of the course
the topic of the phd in the topic of the
program was about how you can use this
kind of scientific management to solve
these big problems like climate change
and as i was studying in particular my
phd was on the topic of biofuels so you
know ethanol and biodiesel which they
make from plants which is just an
absolutely insane abomination of the
humanity it's it's a saying that people
do this you know you
you grow crops you use up land for a
year to grow crops and then to process
them and then to turn them into fuel
when you can just get fuel straight out
of the earth and much cheaper much more
and much better quality that doesn't
degrade the car and that doesn't destroy
the other soil and
um as i was studying that i was on the
one hand i was struck by the
impossible complexity of the question
and then on the other hand i was
noticing the inescapable uh conclusion
that everything that they're trying to
do here is just making things worse
in fact you know the the idea was that
we're going to save the earth from
climate change by replacing
fossil fuels with
ethanol and biodiesel
but the reality was that you were
chopping down the amazon and
indonesian palm
forests and to turn them into um
sterile
farming land
the midwest and the mississippi valley
or over the u.s was essentially degraded
from all of its soil and then the um the
fertilizer that is just running off from
the mississippi is causing all these
enormous damage to the gulf of mexico
it's it's it's it's insane how much
damage is being done
from this attempt to sort of centrally
plan things from above
and
hayek has a saying where he says you
know we used to suffer from problems we
now suffer from solutions and this so
let me ask you about that like look i've
been struck by exactly this problem
right this is the problem of unintended
consequences
and the irreducible complexity of things
so like we can talk about climate change
the problem of climate change but there
isn't
those words are unbelievably deceiving
because there isn't a problem of climate
change there's
and fifty thousand problems of climate
change and every single one of those is
an unbelievably difficult problem and
the solutions to those problems could
well exist in terrible contradiction to
one another
and so but you get deluded you think
well climate change well i can
understand that the climate that's easy
to say i must be able to conceptualize
that of course you can't
and then
and then it hides the fact that it hides
this under structure of complexity now
you got a glimpse of that and that
instilled
in you this resistance to this fatal
conceit it instilled in you some
humility why doesn't that happen to
other people and why did it happen to
you
um
that's a good question um
i don't know um i think uh i don't know
different people they react in different
ways i just um
i have an insatiable curiosity to
continue to try and understand this
question whereas what i needed to do was
to just
sit down and run a bunch of equations on
a spreadsheet and
say that this is the model and
you know as long as the thing was
internally consistent then
it gets the uh pass and then you get the
degree
maybe it was your training as an
engineer
yes i think actually that is a very good
point yeah yeah because engineers they
really like yeah engineers really like
to build things that work exactly and
you can't hide the fact like you have to
trace the whole thing and how it works
and you try and put
you you have to conceptualize it in your
brain it has to make sense you know
think of the rube goldberg machine
whatever it is you have to follow it
through and then you need to figure out
where it breaks and so thinking of
trying to approach uh you know something
as complex as the global energy market
as an engineer approaches something like
an engine you know a single engine
exactly that's the faithful conceit
because the engine is a product of human
design it's a product of human
constructive design somebody sat there
with a pen and paper or computer program
and designed this engine and then they
iterated on it but
things that are societal institutions
are the products of human action and not
human design you know we don't nobody
sat down and designed the global energy
market everybody out there is helping
shape the global energy market every day
with their consumption decisions and
with their production decisions and
everybody's kind of reacting to
everybody else's actions in this kind of
global
dance that we all do together that ends
up you know rewarding the better ideas
and punishing the worst ideas and nobody
knows how it's going to evolve that's
ultimately you know mises critique of
socialism is
primarily about property rights it's the
issue of calculation without property
rights it's impossible for people who
don't own resources and who don't have
an opportunity cost
uh to the use of resources to accurately
and rationally estimate what is the best
use of those resources
it has to be
real you know mises has a beautiful
quote he says you know capital is not a
play it's not play pretend or something
along those lines it's not a game where
you can just let's pretend that this is
my capital i'm going to allocate no it
it has to be worth what it actually is
worth to you individually so that the
decision
has the
weight
yes the full weight of the reward and
the full cost
you have to feel it in order to be able
to understand the decision if you don't
own it then you don't understand the
costs and you don't understand
and you won't can't make that decision
so that's one hand it's the property
rights and calculation critique and then
on the other hand there's the
entrepreneurship critique which is even
if we manage to let's say take over a
capitalist functioning society and turn
it into social society today it has no
possibility for accommodating change it
has no possibility for making change
happen because it has no mechanism for
consumers to impose
their preferences
for the quality and
quantity of goods that they want on the
producers
right so there's no there's no way of
gathering information about the state of
the market
absolutely yeah
and about the future and this is the
crucial role of the entrepreneur because
the entrepreneurs
plays a central role in austrian
economics but not in mainstream
economics because in austrian economics
you know the entrepreneur is the one who
foresees possibilities and most
entrepreneurs are likely wrong perhaps
maybe most or maybe close to most
they're wrong about what they foresee in
the world but
some of them are the ones who build the
truth right well and there's a there's a
darwinian
issue there too because look part of the
rationale for evolution for the for the
uh what would you say for
understanding
why the idea of evolution is necessarily
true in some sense is exactly the
problem of the complexity of the future
it's unpredictable in principle
you're not going to get smart enough to
predict it that's never going to happen
it maybe that would partly be because if
you built a machine that was smart
enough to predict it the existence of a
machine that smart would change the way
that the future would manifest itself in
a way that that machine couldn't predict
and so the way evolution solves that
problem is that
it produces
it's like
there's a million one mosquito gives
rise to a million mosquitoes but every
mosquito doesn't produce a successful
million offspring we'd be like knee deep
in mosquitoes in no time hardly any of
those mosquitoes live
and they've the ones that live vary a
little bit from their parents in some
unforeseen direction
and if you get enough of that production
of unforeseen variants then
some of those unforeseen variants
can match the unforeseeable future and
that's how that's exactly how
entrepreneurs work is most entrepreneurs
fail
and then when you look at successful
entrepreneurs you see that most of their
ideas failed
and so what you do is overproduce and
cull and that's not the same as logical
prediction now there is some role that
intelligence plays right because by all
things considered you'd hope that more
intelligent
entrepreneurs
you would predict that more intelligent
entrepreneurs have a higher probability
of success than less intelligent
entrepreneurs but it isn't necessary
because they're better able to foresee
the future
you know it might be that they're making
better rational decisions of the sort of
rational decision that intelligence can
make
but
so it's very interesting to me that you
say that the
so the entrepreneurs in some sense
their function is to keep the system
modifying itself
to
keep up with the transforming present
that we call the future
that's the role of the entrepreneur and
even psychologically that's the case
they're high in openness and open people
psychologically over produce ideas
they're fascinated by ideas and they
tend to be they have high verbal fluency
they have high fluency in the ability to
generate images so for example
someone who's creative if you say to
someone creative write down as many
words as you can that begin with the
letter s in three minutes the creative
people will on average outperform the
uncreative people that's and that's a
consequence of trade openness and that's
a consequence in part of its association
with high levels of g
fluid intelligence
so it's just speed in some sense and
there's also
very
the other thing that the creative people
do is they'll produce more divergent
answers how many different uses can you
think of for a brick
you score that by number of uses
generated but then also by
the
rarity of the use that's specified extra
points so to speak are given for that
so so the so the way that nature solves
the problem of the unpredictability of
the future even within human
psychological functioning is by over
production and culling not by rational
prediction
yes and um you know one saying i think
it's popper who said this
but it may be appropriately attributed
to him but it is
to predict the wheel is to invent the
wheel that's i think the issue of
prediction like we're to predict the
future is to basically try and predict
what the future of knowledge is and
we're at the limit of our knowledge
right now so
you know the invention of the wheel was
a new thing you had to actually invent
it in order to be able to predict it
because you didn't even know that it was
possible before you uh
before it was invented and this is
ultimately working something something
new is by definition outside of your
domain of knowledge it might even be
outside the axiomatic structure of your
domain of knowledge if it's new enough
and so it's unpredictable by definition
or it wouldn't be
new and it doesn't matter you know the
creativity is not uh you know it's not
like you can pick the 100 most creative
people in the country and then put them
in a room and tell them come up with all
the creative things
uh the whole point is that it's it's a
living ecosystem in which the creativity
is what makes the new ideas and these
like these ideas are tested in the real
world you know they either sink or swim
in the real world of the market and it's
it's it's specifically they're you know
sinking or swimming is
what determines their success because
that's all that matters so you need
those people to be out there in every
field of life in order to be able to
innovate in those fields you can't just
isolate and so a system that is built on
central planning and this this is one of
the critiques that mises has leveled at
socialism exactly a century ago in 1922
he wrote his book socialism and until
today i don't think there has been a
single socialist that has actually
illustrated their ability to comprehend
this point and still disagree with it
like they all just completely ignore it
it's not something that anybody they
they
grapple with his ideas on property
rights and they made some attempts to
refute him and failed in my opinion but
on the entrepreneurship point there's
almost complete silence because there's
no way that you can square the idea of
letting you know every
uh every workshop worker have the
opportunity to create and innovate
something new and try it out because
they have their own money and then they
start their own shop you know there's no
way that you can square that with having
a committee that decides all of these
workshops that are doing this in this
this line of business
that all of their capital all their work
all of their structure all of their um
everything that they do has to be
decided by central authority those two
things are fundamentally incompatible
so we're still walking through
the bitcoin standard at least in some
sense shall we talk more about the fiat
standard the book that you've just
released and so let's talk first of all
tell everybody what constitutes a fiat
currency and contrast that with bitcoin
and and and have adder
all right so let me just uh conclude
with one more thing about bitcoin
standard and the austrian school because
i think it's a good recap of everything
we've discussed so far which is that um
you know practically speaking the men
where the rubber hits the road in terms
of the difference between the austrians
and everybody else
is in the uh
free market conception of money versus
the status conception of money this is
where you know the two world views are
the most divergent because from the
mainstream perspective everybody in the
mainstream you know the money is the
creation of the state and the only
question is what is the state's role in
the management of money but from the
austrian perspective money is a product
of the market
and the state um not the money is not
the invention of the state and the
state's meddling in money
is actually not just uh
not just
you know irrational in the sense of it
can't succeed for all the reasons that
uh socialist central planning cannot
succeed it's also at the root of the
cause it's also the root cause of the
majority of economic problems that all
economists are concerned with
so once you and i've and i heard your
discussion with robert murphy who did a
great job explaining the business cycle
it's the
it's the corruption of money that
ultimately leads to the business cycle
and up until bitcoin came about
this was an interesting um philosophical
discussion and economic and academic
discussion uh but there was very few
there were very few austrian economists
and the majority of everybody just went
along with what the mainstream thought
but the absolutely fascinating thing
about bitcoin
one of the many fascinating things about
bitcoin is that it is a live experiment
in this question here we go we have a
form of money that is not produced by
the state not regulated by the state not
controlled by the state
and
um it's functioning as a form of money
and it tests you know it
its continued survival refutes the state
theory of money and
uh perhaps even more deliciously it
refutes the inflationist theories of
money which all of these other schools
are inflationists you know they all
argue about how much the money supply
should increase and how should the money
supply increase and who should be in
charge of the money supply increase but
none of them has ever questioned the
fundamental proposition which is the
money supply should not increase does
not have to increase and if we so why do
they presume that it should increase
um i mean
intellectually you know the whole
field is shaped from the perspective of
how should the government manage the
money successfully and so
there's no way that you
as somebody who's getting paid from the
increase of the supply there's no
you know
the overturn window of acceptable
answers for you through self-censorship
uh more than or intellectual capture is
you know how do we increase the money
supply but you know if there's no money
supply increase you most likely don't
get a salary because your job is linked
to that printer and
essentially i think you know a less
charitable interpretation by an austrian
economist of a mainstream economist is
that
they're essentially court jesters for
the inflationary central bank so the
central banks need an intellectual
apparatus that gets on tv and says you
know we have to print all this money in
order to
prevent
unemployment from happening and to
prevent bad things from happening but
really
i think you know the bigger story here
is the money printing of course is
highly lucrative for
governments and so of course governments
are highly favorable of people who
want that so bitcoin is powerful in this
regard because a
you know economically it's succeeding
and intellectually it's succeeding as
well i think this is it's a massive
challenge to the um mainstream economics
establishment their complete inability
to explain it or to try and prevent
present an um
a coherent explanation for why it
behaves the way it does or why it grows
is absolutely astonishing you know it's
been there for 12 years it's worth a
trillion dollars right now
and
the vast majority of university
professors will tell you oh it's just a
tulip somehow they're convinced that the
fact that you know um agricultural
product prices went up for a few months
in amsterdam in the 17th century somehow
invalidates the fact that we have a form
of money that travels internationally
and is hard and is completely outside
the state the state the control of the
state it's it it its argument might
sound bite almost they haven't even
given it much thought because there's
not much
to say it's argument by dismissive
analogy
yes which is very common also in the uh
climate change discussion as you always
notice
yeah you see i mean it's not that i i
spend a lot of time looking at the
climate change literature and and
considering solutions for various
reasons and
i can never stop being more afraid of
the solutions than the problem
and it's not like i'm not afraid of the
problem it's conceivable that human
activity is producing global climate
change and i think the evidence for that
seems to be relatively robust although
the economic how economically
consequential that will be is subject to
tremendous debate because it's
prediction out 100 years or 50 years and
like good luck with that boys and girls
but the solutions terrify me
so
and uh and in fact i discussed this in
the fiat standard okay i use this as an
as an uh
as an example of how fiat corrupts the
planet basically so um in in the bitcoin
standard a lot of bitcoin standard was
about government money but uh you could
always say more because it's just been
so enormously important over the last
100 years so in the fiat standard i take
the same kind of analytical lens that i
used in the bitcoin standard to look at
bitcoin which was you know when i
started writing that book it was this
obscure thing that only a bunch of
weirdos on the internet had heard about
and i tried to kind of come at the same
uh with the same kind of lens
at the fiat system and trying to ignore
all the hoopla of a century of
propaganda and academic work yeah well i
you know
sorry your discussion already has made
me aware of all sorts of
axioms of my thought that i didn't know
i had
so for example i basically just accepted
in some sense
on faith the idea that
money is
the government's fundamentally
the money i know we all have our money
and we own it but
it's a state
construct that's why each country has
its own currency and so
one of the functions of the government
is to deal with money and the idea that
you could abstract that away from the
government
any government any conceivable
conceivably forever or at least forever
as far as we're concerned
it's hard to wrap it's hard to wrap my
head around how radical an idea that is
i i don't know what that would mean if
it was actually true
and so
and i the idea
that i mean the arguments that you've
presented
that suggest that the notion that
government control of that the
government has valid control over money
and maybe that that should be subject in
some sense to the democratic process
rather than the market process
you know it's going to take me a long
time to think that through because that
really is a radical
it's unbelievably radical proposition
yes that's kind of why the austrians are
kind of
ostracized and considered outside the
pale on this issue but think about it
you know no government declared gold as
money gold emerged as money all over the
world independently because of its uh
because of its properties and then
governments had to use gold in their own
currencies in order to give their
currencies value you know if you wanted
your
picture on a coin and you wanted that
coin to circulate and for people to hold
it and appreciate it you had to make
that coin out of gold you couldn't just
make coins out of um anything and give
it to people and when people tried to do
that
uh hilarity and calamity ensued in uh
every case you know we have a long
history of what happens when governments
debase currency and you know it always
happens in the same way they begin by
making sound money they they specify the
weight and they make it uniform but then
they
almost always i think although every
example in history has ended up with
them um basically succumbing to the
temptation to increase the supply if it
was paper money backed by gold or to
what they used to do previously which is
uh mix and base metals where yeah wasn't
it the case that the the ridges on these
edges of coins were there because the
coins were shaved by slightly and was
that a government was that a state
function or were people doing that to
coins i'm sorry i just this is just an
example of how that solid
uh
uncorruptable currency can be you know
if you get a gold coin you can you can
scrape some of the gold off and if you
have enough gold coins you can make a
nice pile of gold dust and the gold
coins still work but you have the gold
and so there's various ways of doing
that and i read that the ridges on the
outside of coins why do they have them
they
now do you know is that the case or am i
just chasing something that's not the
case at all do you i i think i've heard
stories like that yeah there's so many
stories historically of governments
finding creative ways of debasing their
currencies you know the most common one
is oh no some people are making fake
currency so give us all of your currency
so we can mint it again into a new form
so that we can make sure that it's uh
right and then you get your currency
back and then it has five percent less
gold than it used to have that's that
was kind of the quantitative easing that
they did before and that they take some
of that gold for themselves
so that
that has always that temptation has
always been there and bitcoin is
essentially
the most powerful defensive technology
against that it's it's
it's an enormous quantum leap forward in
the technology of money
as as protection of value
against predation and against inflation
because you know the you you don't have
to worry about whether the coin has base
metal inside it you can verify
everything with bitcoin and um it's it's
it's fully auditable everybody can see
every single transaction
and uh everybody can verify the rules of
the network so it's the most powerful
technology that we have for money and i
think it's it's a natural fit to anybody
who's productive and wants to save their
value into the future and it's not just
a fit for them i think the beautiful
thing about it is that it is
uh it's a great reward for them it's a
great reward for those people to go and
um you know save into the future and
this is why i think bitcoin is uh
uh is is so
um transformative to the individual
because it um gives you a better way of
saving for the future and i think this
is something i discuss extensively in
the bitcoin standard i think that's uh
highly related to the time preference of
individuals which is an enormously
important topic so
historically all throughout human
history you know we're always moving to
a harder money because we're looking for
a better form of money and that
culminated by the end of the 19th
century with everybody in the world
being on the classical gold standard
basically the entire planet was on the
same currency
one money chosen on the market
very hard to produce holding on to its
value offering anybody in the world the
ability to save for their future
essentially for free you know you you
get paid in the coin you keep the coin
safe and then 20 years later that coin
is not only held on to its value it's
likely appreciated more because in those
20 years we've made more cars more
houses more apples more oranges more
everything but we haven't made a lot
more gold so the gold coins remains
valuable and so historically you see
this has coincided with a decline in
interest rates which from the austrian
perspective is a measure of time
preference a time preference is what
determines interest rate and time
preference is the degree of discounting
for the future so effectively as long as
we're using harder and harder money we
are being able to provide for the future
better
and that's
reducing our uncertainty of the future
you know now you're you can be
fairly confident that the money that you
worked for today that you can save and
it'll be there for you in five years
time when you start thinking more about
yourself in five years time
and as our technology for money has
improved and as our ability to save has
improved our time horizon has expanded
our time preferences dropped we start
thinking more and more about the future
that encourages to say encourages us to
save more to invest more and then that
leads to capital accumulation which
leads to the increase in productivity
and i think
the whole world was basically lowering
its time preference until the early 20th
century and then in the early 20th
century this is kind of the central
argument of the fiat standard by
switching to
an easy money where now you know in the
20th century we moved to government
money which has been increasing
on average i calculate at something like
roughly 14 a year
globally so you move from a money supply
that's being inflated at one or two
percent as the average human being in
the world you had that same gold coin
now you're stuck with your government's
local script
that is inflating at on average 14 you
know some people have witnessed 200
percent inflation so so that on average
so you said worldwide if you just took
western democracies into account
say relatively stable
societies with relatively admirable
forms of government what sort of
inflation rate are you looking at
do you know that
yeah i've done the numbers in the fiat
standard the lowest averages you'll see
are in the us switzerland denmark and
sweden and they're about six to seven
percent per year over the last 50 60
years so that's really as good as it
gets for fiat as a kind of average so
you're constantly you know so you need a
return of six percent or seven percent
just to keep up
basically yeah and you know seven
percent is is is not nothing seven
percent means you basically lose half
the value stored in ten years and that's
seven percent that's in the good cases
there are countries that have had an
average of 200 because you know they had
years in which the money supply went up
tenfold within one year and that that
has happened so you think about the
examples of people living in
hyperinflationary societies and i used
to live in lebanon until recently and
you see that when the currency collapses
you know think about the stories about
weimar germany or about any latin
american country or lebanon or zimbabwe
when you hear about their inflation
you know the stories are of people that
have been reduced to
very very very uh short-term thinking
your money you get paid in the beginning
of the month your money is going to be
worth half of its price by the end of
its by the end of the month so you get
paid and you run straight to the
supermarket i remember i was a kid
growing up in brazil and i remember that
you know the first day of the month the
supermarkets would be overrun and there
would be people fighting and things
would be crazy because everybody's
trying to get things now before
everybody else gets their paycheck and
buys everything and then bids up the
price
so
your
whole time horizon is shortened when
your money is losing its value okay so
let me let me ask okay let me ask you a
question about that then too so
one of the
problems that the people who are
concerned about the environment and
about global warming are are trying to
solve is
they're trying to increase our sense of
caring for
let's call it the planet the environment
right global concern think globally act
locally
you're supposed to be taking all these
other things into account and not
consuming like a madman and despoiling
the planet but implicit in your argument
as far as i can tell is that if you
stabilize the currency so it can't be
inflated and you make people's time
horizon much
longer that they're going to be
concerned about a far greater variety of
things that are distal from them
like the environment
because they can
they're now able to do that instead of
having to fight for short-term emergency
survival continually exactly exactly
that's it that's so the more capital you
accumulate the more you can provide for
the future the more you can secure the
present and start thinking about the
future you know the more you care about
the future then in some sense or can
care about it
and and and you know you think about it
like the the fisherman who's able to
move toward building a fishing boat and
a fishing rod you know they're able to
now rest assured that any day they just
need a small amount of time to go
out and catch the fish it's not like the
days when they had nothing and they had
to try and catch them with their hands
every day and so some days you might not
be able to even catch anything so now
your survival is more secure and so you
start thinking more about the future and
money is an incredible technology for
that for lowering our time preference
that's kind of one of my central
arguments in the fiat standard that
money is the best mechanism we have for
moving value to the future because you
know you could save a fishing boat and
you can save something else but you
don't know what's going to happen in the
future and you don't know if you want to
move away from where you are money
itself is enormously important because
it's very useful you save some money and
then doesn't matter what happens in your
town you take the money and you can go
away so it protects you against the
uncertainty of the future and when that
money is compromised
your ability to think of the future is
massively compromised as well and i
think you know the hyperinflationary
examples are an extreme example of that
but i think the 20th century itself was
one global
slow train wreck of watching humanity's
time preference rise
as you know generation after generation
of people all over the world
witnessed their currency devalued
everybody saw it there isn't a single
people in the world that have escaped
this you know it doesn't matter if you
live in western europe or africa or
latin america everybody has been screwed
by inflation in the 20th century and
everybody has a story in their family
about somebody who saved up and worked
hard and diligently and then one day
they woke up and all their money was
gone and all the wealth that they worked
for was gone everybody has gone through
this and it
it leaves a mark it leaves a mark it
tells you know don't be the sucker who
saves for tomorrow because you know you
missed out on all you see like in in in
weimar germany you think about the
people who are punished by that
hyperinflation those were people who
were productive
and who and who had foresight because
they put away something for the future
it the ants were published punished not
the grasshoppers
you know
and that's a terrible thing to do to a
society to take the most creative people
who also have the ability to delay
gratification
and then to just
cut them off at the knees for daring to
to do both of those things you couldn't
do a worse thing to a society in some
sense than that to punish people for for
for creativity productivity and the
capacity to save instead of the
pursuit of impulsive pleasure so it is
really a catastrophe
so it absolutely is
and and maybe that's not much improved
when it's a slow train wreck rather than
a quick one i mean who knows right so
um
all right yeah i mean the speed has
varied but i think um
this has been the story of the 20th
century and on the flip side of it which
is kind of the
the two sides of the story that i tell
in the fiat standard on the one hand you
know you had individual productive
people and businesses having their
wealth robbed from them continuously
throughout the 20th century because it's
constantly devaluing and on the other
hand you had government bureaucracies
being given essentially unlimited
financing to do whatever they want
because they were connected to the
printing press and all that you needed
was to just have the right story in the
ear of the right person to get the
printing press to run for you and so you
know not only are you punishing the most
productive people in society and the
people that are the best at saving for
the future and thinking in the future
you're also essentially rewarding
heavily people who are good at playing
politics
and uh people who can you know get into
government and people who can use
government power because
you are giving those people unlimited
power so naturally you're going to our
prime minister our prime minister
managed to get a billion dollars into
the hands of one of the charities he's
associated with
yes i've heard of that your prime
minister has been an excellent lesson in
what happens when seemingly idealist
people with beautiful sounding cliches
get into power and then
have that power foisted upon them and
then
they they see in a great opportunity to
capitalize on that to their own benefit
and to their own aggrandizement
um
you know
and all the while justifying it by
reference to their their their the moral
standards they hold that exceed those of
everyone else
absolutely absolutely
and then you know you think about it
first so there's the aspect of the
corruption of the fact that you know
playing politics pays
but then there's the other aspect which
to go back to the energy discussion and
the food discussion which i discussed in
the fiat standard
these markets then become heavily
regulated and influenced by a government
that has an infinite printing press
to the point where um
that they've been made almost
dysfunctional at this point so uh if you
think in in terms of energy we've had
and and both energy and food you know
the the current hysteria that you hear
around oh no we're going to boil the
oceans uh because we're driving cars or
you know we're going to boil the ocean
because we're eating cows and cows are
farting and you know four and a half
billion years of earth was doing fine
until the cows started to fart and now
the whole earth is going to hell
both of these hysterias incidentally
have their roots in the inflation of the
1970s it was when the prices of food and
energy rose in the 1970s there are all
these cranky kooky ideas about you know
earth punishing us
and there's not enough
resources for us to be able to live and
we need to limit the global population
and we're destroying the earth all that
stuff started to come about in the 1970s
and it was highly politically um
conducive at that point it was likely to
be popular because
it was providing a very
useful alibi
to
the government when it comes to
inflation you know the reason we are
witnessing massive increases in the
price of oil and food has nothing to do
with the fact that your currency is
being printed and debased it's because
we've reached the natural carrying
limits of the earth and we're going to
boil the oceans and we're going to
destroy the planet and so you know you
need to repent by moving away from
consuming
hydrocarbon energy you know oil and gas
and coal and all of those things that
made our modern world and the things
that are the reason that we have our
modern world and modern technology we
can't live without them they're 80
percent of energy consumption around the
globe and
that's not declining in any meaningful
sense any time soon unless we want to go
back to pre-industrial societies
and so
you know
by fiat we've uh tried to
we fought these energy sources for 50
years and subsidize these feel-good
essentially pre-industrial unworkable
technologies which rely on biomass so
biofuels as an example you know you're
burning plants like your ancestors 500
years ago had to do in order to survive
or wind which again you know your
ancestors could use occasionally but
it didn't build them
it didn't build them apple computers
and it didn't build the internet and
solar energy which you know also we've
always used but again
it won't build you a car
in order to have all these modern
conveniences that we have we need those
energies and people in the fiat world
are completely dissociated from this
reality they almost want it
they almost want to overrule
thermodynamics by fiat that we just want
we want to have the same cars better
cars but we don't want them to run on
fuels we want them to run on
wind and solar and all that and
the result of that i think you know when
i was doing my phd i saw this for the
grift that it was um and i was not
interested in it intellectually because
you know who cares a bunch of people
like al gore are going to become
billionaires from this but you know a
lot of hucksters get rich in a lot of
ways
no reason to get worked up but now i
think i'm beginning to realize this is
actually a serious serious
threat
to
industrialization and civilization
itself i mean our planet
will witness massive catastrophes and
calamities if
reduction or if we have a serious
reduction in the consumption of these
energy sources which you know plants are
being decommissioned all over the world
based on the idea that we're going to be
replacing it with wind and solar and the
result is energy prices are rising
massively
and
you know energy is becoming less and
less reliable you're witnessing more and
more grid failures
yeah
all right so on to the fiat standard
yes
so in the fiat standard looking at the
uh looking at the way that the fiat
money works as um you know from first
principles trying to understand how it
works i think the the fundamental idea
is that
in the fiat system the way that you mine
a new currency into existence is through
lending
you when you when your bank makes a new
loan
they don't take somebody else's money
and give it to you they
make new money essentially out of thin
air and they hand it to you and they put
it in your bank account so
this i think is a very key insight so
we have that walk through that so
everyone understands exactly what the
banks are doing because that is not
something that people know or understand
yeah so it's it's not like there's a
fixed sum of money that the bank has to
deal with where and you know they need
to get depositors money and then they
need to lend it out to borrowers if you
have a lending license if you're a bank
you're licensed by your local central
bank
the mere fact that you have that lending
license means that you can issue loans
and um essentially create new money and
add new money to the money supply and
put it in your
clients bank account
so
now obviously they can't just do this
limitlessly there are regulations and
rules by the central bank that determine
how much lending is done
and so what are the rules approximately
well the rules is you know the person
who borrows has to have a good
credit history and good credit standing
and a good idea good reason for why they
want to borrow it but obviously these
things are getting
less and less strict over time as
monetary expansion picks up and
political pressure for more and more
monetary expansion increases these
credits right you saw that with the
housing with the housing
crash yeah yeah housing is one example
but i think you know perhaps the even
bigger example is the financial industry
which is constantly receiving enormous
amounts of new credit from the central
bank directly in the form of
quantitative easing that's a huge one
so you know in in bitcoin we have
bitcoin mining which is an extremely uh
sophisticated industry in order to
produce new bitcoins you know we have
about six and a quarter bitcoins
produced every 10 minutes
and um in order to produce these people
expend a lot of resources in order to be
able to make them roughly the cost of
making a bitcoin fluctuates around the
market price of bitcoin but both vary
but it's roughly around it with gold the
same is true as well you know it's it's
costly and expensive to find new gold
you have to dig and you have to process
it and it's
there okay so so so why bother mining it
and why not just cap bitcoin where it is
now why bother producing more why is
that built into the system why 21
million and not just where we are now
well 21 million is as good as any number
it could have been 500 trillion it could
have been five it could have been
anything um any number is good enough as
long as it's divisible and that's kind
of the
key insight from the austrians that made
me specifically very interested in
bitcoin the austrians were the only one
who said yeah the quantity of money
doesn't matter you could run any economy
on any size of the money and then as the
um as the economy grows the value of the
money increases and that's a great thing
that's that's the golden period that's
the golden age of the west so it's sort
of an it's a sort of an illusion in some
sense the cap because well there's 21
million bitcoin let's say but they could
be worth anywhere from like two dollars
to
a million dollars each and because it's
it's fractionable
right so so there is no in that sense
there's no limit to how much money there
is even though there's a limit to how
many tokens there are exactly there's no
limit to the value that the network can
carry but there's a limit to the tokens
that represent that value
so you don't corrupt the tokens of the
system in order to make more tokens in
order to enrich the insiders you just
keep packing more value into it into the
tokens okay so why why
why are they why was it allowed
to be mined at all then
so that the distribution of the coins
would be a fair distribution so that
anybody could enter into the network and
secure coins because that you know if if
you just made the first 21 million you
know who owns them
in the first day who's going to be
owning the 21 million how are you going
to distribute them this is not an easy
question and i think you know most
people um
most people uh
wouldn't have thought something like
bitcoin to be possible had it not
because of this issue you know how are
you going to start off an upstart
currency and give everybody in the world
a new balance so it was to get it going
exactly it's so you know it's kind of
like just for the first 130 years
of bitcoin's history we're going to need
to have mining but then bitcoin operates
without any more mining right so you
have some you need some gold for gold to
work and so you need to have a mechanism
for mining the gold and so this is some
mechanism for producing bitcoin so that
there are some bitcoins so it can work
and they're distributed across the
people who have done the mining and so
you already have a bit of an economy
there because all those people are
vested in it and it's completely
open and perfectly competitive anybody
in the world can mine anybody can bring
their computer onto the network and mine
and you know
benefit from the mining and it's it
rewards only the most uh successful
miners introverts only the most economic
miners because it has this thing called
the difficulty adjustment which is um my
favorite part of bitcoin it's it's
really the magic glue that holds bitcoin
together and i discuss it in the bitcoin
standard and in the fiat standard
um what happens is that uh you know if
more miners try and mine copper or gold
or silver you end up with a lot more
copper or so gold or silver but with
bitcoin the more miners that get into
the network you still get the same
number of bitcoin as was predetermined
earlier
but the difference is that you don't get
uh
but it just gets harder for the
individual miners to uh
uh get into the network so it's it's
more like a sports competition where and
there's one trophy and then the more
competitors get in the trophy just gets
harder to win it doesn't get
you don't get more trophies handed out
so how how in the world did satoshi
figure this out how did he i don't
understand how he could conceptualize
this
it just doesn't make sense to me
it's an incredible work of genius when
you think about just the the the amount
of uh expertise that he had to have in
different fields of knowledge to bring
this monster together is absolutely
astounding yeah well just just the
conceptualization to begin with let
alone the in the implementation the
engineering implementation it's to be
fair i mean this
it wasn't like he invented this problem
it's it's a problem that had been around
for many decades people had been trying
to build a digital form of money
for decades you know since the 1970s and
80s and 90s have been attempts to do
something like this
and the
um you know the different attempts to
produce something like this always came
up against uh
a technical problem called the byzantine
generals problem and then satoshi
figured out a solution to it through the
proof of work system which is absolutely
astounding
so
tell me about that that sounds if we can
do that without deviating too much so
what is that problem and how did he
solve it um well the problem is uh
essentially about how to get all the
different uh nodes on the network to
agree on the same version of what's
going to happen
together you know how the how do they
all agree without having a central
command authority that's really the
issue
so um and why was that the byzantine
general's problem
you know
ashamed to say it but i'm not up very
much up on my history i'm not sure where
the history of the term comes from okay
okay well i won't torture you with that
then but
but he solved to solve the problem of
consensus verification without a central
authority exactly and the way to do it
was to have this expensive
uh ritual called proof-of-work being
performed before any of the members of
the network proposes
a block of transactions to be added onto
the record of transactions so bitcoin is
um you know
it's a record of transactions that exist
over tens of thousands of computers and
the issue is how are you how do you make
sure that people don't put in fake
transactions in this record well the way
he did it was that anybody anywhere in
the world could come in and propose new
transactions but in order to have your
transactions added you must first solve
this problem this mathematical problem
the proof-of-work mathematical problem
and that's actually expensive to solve
you know it takes your computer running
for many many hours to be able to try
and figure out solution to those things
and um you know for it to get lucky once
every 10 minutes so you have to spend
serious money in order to be able to
commit uh to make the claim of the new
transactions and so once you know it's
like
uh if you just allow everybody to
present their record of transactions
then there's no mechanism of
coordinating between everybody whose
record do we pick from all those
thousands of people but if you put
currently you know the reward is about
six uh six and a half seven bitcoin so
that's about 350 thousand dollars the
bitcoin network is giving out 350 000
every 10 minutes
you can have them as long as you provide
the proof of work solution which roughly
costs you around 350 000 more or less so
how do we make sure that we can all
agree on this
uh all the members of the network we
don't evaluate any claim for the
transactions we only evaluate the claim
that has done the work and that has
spent the money so why would why would
someone make that claim then if it's so
difficult what's the advantage to that
you get three hundred fifty thousand
dollars you get six or seven bitcoins
and how is that how is that related
that's the mining process that's the
mining that is the mining process that
is the mine okay good exactly oh i got
it that's the mining process exactly so
to mine new bitcoins you have to solve
that problem so this is why it's
portrayed as mining it's like those
computers are digging in the ground
trying to find the solution of the
mathematical problem it costs money to
be able to arrive at that solution on
average around 350 000 currently at
current prices
so
that's
in order to be able to make a claim to
get that you know your claim doesn't get
looked at unless you've solved the
problem and it's very cheap for
everybody on the network to see that you
have the right solution to the problem
but it's very expensive to arrive at
that solution so the solution is like
this very difficult key to find but once
you've found it it's trivial to verify
that this is the right key because you
just put it in the lock and it works so
it's instantaneous and very cheap for
members of the network to figure out
that this thing is correct
so you set up this massive hurdle
essentially
um if anybody wants to come and get this
reward they first need to spend why
wouldn't they just buy bitcoin it seems
to be to be a lot simpler than mining it
then if it costs 350 dollars to make
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
why bother with the mining
you know you said it it rewards more
efficient people
exactly the short answer is if you have
a way of securing electricity at less
than five cents per kilowatt hour then
um you should get into a bitcoin mining
business
uh which is you know lower than most
rates everywhere in the world so if you
have a source of energy that is isolated
then from the grid or if you have a
cheap way of securing energy then
bitcoin is a great uh weight mining
bitcoin is great but for the most
so does that mean that bitcoin is a very
good way of moving resources from places
that can produce electricity very
cheaply to other places where
electricity is more expensive does that
actually make the electricity the cheap
electricity it makes the cheap
electricity much more valuable
absolutely it's uh this is weird that's
a weird thing
it's it's very weird i think it's going
to have a very profound impact on the
global energy market because for the
first time in history we have a way to
sell energy that is location independent
so a lot of places in the world have a
lot of energy but it's very expensive to
get that to the population center so the
north of canada hasn't so you don't need
wires
exactly jesus that's weird that's a
really strange thing yeah to get
electricity from the north of ontario to
toronto re needs a lot of wires or you
need to you know if it was gas you need
to put it on tankers or on trains or in
pipelines all of that stuff is pretty
expensive but with bitcoin you just need
an internet connection you take the
bitcoin miners to where that energy is
and then you can monetize that energy
and turn it into bitcoin it's magic so
what's the what's the net effect of that
on the price of electricity worldwide is
that does that is that deflationary with
regards to electricity cost i think so i
think this is this is a point that i
make in the fiat standard which is that
you know we've had fiat subsidize all
these dysfunctional forms of energy over
the last 50 years that have led to the
grid becoming unreliable
and we have bitcoin
like the
vigilante savior that it is coming in
and providing a global subsidy for
anybody who can make electricity at a
cheap rate to monetize that
and i think well not only at a global
subsidy but it's so but so interesting
because
not only you could go
to where the energy is cheap with
virtual certainty that you're going to
make more and more money
as the value of the bitcoin increases by
by investing there assuming you assume
that the value of bitcoin is going to
continually increase which is a logical
presupposition if it's if it's as stable
as as is claimed
and
it's finite
in the way that you're describing
and increasingly widely accepted by vast
numbers of people so it's also an
investment
that's likely to
increase in value over time rather than
decrease so it takes some of the
uncertainty out of investing in
cheap electricity generating processes
that are geographically
isolated that's i just can't believe
that's true it's it's amazing that
i i i think i must be misunderstanding
because it seems like you can move the
value of the electricity electricity
magically
without any of the problems of
transportation yes exactly
wow that's really something okay and and
in terms of you know think about it in
terms of independence i think the
implications are pretty good because if
you have an energy source you know it
becomes far more sustainable to be able
to
exploit that energy source if you have a
steady way of monetizing it so i think
it can help people get off the grid that
can help people become more independent
um you know you have your own energy
sources and you have your own um
a monetary system that you use to trade
with the rest of the world
you don't need much of the
control of the grid on you which is
getting more and more suffocating every
day
yes and as as this idea that we're
despoiling the planet and our technical
activities our industrial activities our
high standard of living all that's
immoral because we're doing immeasurable
long-term harm to this pristine
biosphere
like that you can just feel the moral
pressure growing there just it intensely
intensely intensely yeah and i think
it's it's it's completely ridiculous
because
you know every action has a cost and
this is the thing about it you learn
from economics everything has a cost
everything has an opportunity cost and
people like to present this idea as if
you know there's an evil cabal of oil
producers that are out there forcing our
governments to make our lives dependent
on these oils and what we need to do is
to just have the political will to
transition to these more advanced forms
of energy that are going to save the
planet and it's just completely
ridiculous
well people people don't understand like
people don't understand things as simple
as the fact that there's a finite amount
of solar energy that falls on a square
yard of of territory
that that at that basic level of physics
it's just while the sun is an
inexhaustible source of energy it's like
well that's true but
practically speaking that's not exactly
the issue exactly because what you need
is the power what you want is to convert
that high quantity of energy into high
power which is a lot of energy over a
small short period of time and to do
that
this is this is really understanding
that what humans look for is not energy
because energy is everywhere you know
there's sun and there's wind and all of
that stuff but being able to channel
that in order in in order to use it in
high power applications that's what
makes everything that we value possible
that's what makes surviving the winter
a breeze for the vast majority of us you
know this is why we have our modern
lights that's why we have transportation
because we have high power and the way
that we've managed to secure high power
the way that we've built our world is
modern hydrocarbons and so
the thing that uh carbon people who are
afraid of carbon dioxide need to present
is
they need to make the case that you know
stopping hydrocarbons
is
going to have such a noticeable effect
on the climate
that it outweighs the benefits of taking
yeah
they're not going to do that because
like you look you look at how how this
works out is that
you know we're trying to calculate the
economic consequences of climate change
and the economic consequences of our
interventions over this this has to do
with the time preference over say 50 to
100 years but the errors in your
measurements and your predictions grow
and grow and grow as you move out
decades into the future it's that those
justifications will never be forthcoming
they're they're technically impossible
and so it does it does go down to basic
principles it's like do you believe this
is a problem that can be solved by
intelligent well-meaning people who are
doing central planning and i've toyed
with those ideas worked on u.n
committees that are devoted to uh
what are the u.n millennium goals and i
looked at how that central planning was
done and that's an interesting story in
and of itself because
it isn't even cabell's of experts like
so this committee i was on was composed
of uh you know ex-presidents and prime
ministers and people like that from all
over the world and so you think well
they have some political and economic
expertise they're putting together these
the new vision of the u.n for the new
millennium let's say but those aren't
the people who are actually making the
decisions because they're completely
occupied they already have lives that
are absolutely full so then the
decision-making power falls down the
bureaucracy until it lands on the
shoulders of someone who has spare time
for one reason or another and they make
the decisions in the name of that person
and then all those decisions are
aggregated and there isn't anybody who's
in some sense taking central
responsibility for that
so so that the document that i worked on
to begin with looked like it was written
by people who were stuck in the 1980s it
was all cold war
uh ideology essentially the northern
hemisphere against the southern
hemisphere so we just stripped all that
out
we just took it out and the reason we
were able to get away with that
was that we rewrote it
and no one else wanted to re-rewrite our
rewrite
and so it just stuck and then there was
these 200 millennial goals essentially
and i i looked at that and i thought
well why those goals and the answer was
well there was constituencies of
interest for each of those goals
and then i thought well we need to rank
order these because there's no bloody
way we're going to do all 200.
and
there was no rank ordering and the
reason for that was it would upset all
the constituencies
and i thought well
you get this weird aggregation of things
we need to do
and then the impossibility of of
recording that means you don't have a
priority like what's the most important
and how do you decide that well that
problem just wasn't addressed at all
and so this well it was an object lesson
and how these sorts of things work
it was central planning but it was it
was so dysfunctional in some way
it it's not like it's partly because
there wasn't anyone in the world who had
enough intelligence enough knowledge to
make those sorts of decisions no one
no one exists like that so
well so well i'm going to stop with that
but
yeah i think the the ultimate issue i
think in in these things i i'd go back
to mises point which is that none of
these people is making calculations with
opportunity cost that's the great thing
about the fiat world is that everybody
has essentially a fake fiat job wherein
they get paid regardless of actual
results you know and the fiat world
results are optional because your money
doesn't come from the customer for many
of those people their money comes from
the money printer from up above so it's
not about how you serve
uh the customer it's about whether you
do the things that the people providing
the funding right so it's dissociated
it's dissociated from the actual
environment because the consumer is the
actual environment the consumer is an
actual living being
and if you're serving the consumer then
you have you have nature there as your
witness and your judge and then there
can be all sorts of intermediaries
between that which is what you're
discussing and then that moves the
producer away from feedback from the
consumer and it and it and it what it
corrupts the signal
it corrupts the information signal okay
precisely and that's that's kind of the
other central point in the fiat
standards so in the one hand you're
dropping people of the purchasing power
on the other hand you're putting the
decisions in about people's lives in the
hands of people who essentially face no
opportunity cost and they have these
jobs regardless of whether they perform
them because they're linked to this
magic printer that continues to finance
them so they don't lose their job and
they always can continue to do whatever
it is that they're doing
and
facing no accountability and you know
the impact across life i think is is
enormous because
it leads to all kinds of central
planning it leads to
a and the fundamental problem with this
which you see in the climate change
debate and you see it in the coronavirus
restrictions and response is that all of
these people don't understand the
concept of opportunity cost you know the
zoom warrior class the people whose
lives can be conducted from their
internet connection
they're just completely blind to the
idea that other people need to leave the
house and eat it's it's astonishing to
watch it because in their mind you know
you can call for something like let's
lock everybody at home for you know a
year and a half so that nobody gets sick
except for being locked from being
locked at home
yeah well of course if you don't think
about you know if you don't think about
the downsides of thing then it's a
brilliant idea everything is great if
you just ignore the downsides and that's
essentially what governments can afford
to do because they don't
have the markets discipline to
essentially
correct them and that's
that's what bitcoin brings you know well
the discipline the discipline is exactly
the lack of discipline is exactly you
know so so we could we could
de-personalize this to some degree and
think about it as a technical problem
right is that
as you stack up intermediaries between
the producer and the consumer because
the signal is degraded the responses
aren't going to be accurate reflections
of what's necessary in the environment
and that's sort of ideologically
agnostic
what what you derive from that is you
want to set up systems where those
intermediaries don't exist because then
the signal isn't corrupt and we can act
properly in concert with the with the
dictates of the genuine environment
yes exactly and i in fact i begin the
second section of my fiat standard books
called fiat life it begins with this
idea that all living things face this
natural order of the world in which they
need to produce more than they consume
in order to survive there's just every
cell every animal every plant needs to
do this you know they're constantly
working or they die
or they die exactly and the only
exception to this is essentially the
fiat human
because they don't need to produce
because they can just uh live off
the money printer that comes from them
from above and so i think
we've had an enormous section of the
population
that is not
used to the concept of productive work
it's it's um
it's destroyed the concept of you know
the the moral imperative of work as
service to others when
you take away the fact that
work is also the only way to eat you
know when work becomes optional it
becomes much easier to
it becomes much easier to philosophize
it away and philosophize duty and
responsibility away and that's i think
what fiat does and
you combine that with the fact that it
raises time preference because it
discourages provision for the future and
it discourages people to think a lot of
the future and you can see that a lot of
the problems a lot of the pathology
pathologies of the 20th century
i think have their root in uh highly
inflationary fiat currency
a couple of objections to bitcoin let's
say
um
it's not easily usable
like i can't i can't just go to the
store and buy something with bitcoin
it's not easy and and i don't see that
improving very radically radically now
maybe it's a store of value and there
will be systems built on top of it that
make those sorts of transactions
possible so but maybe you could address
that you you just brushed over
the
the issue of
the multiplicity of of of
cryptocurrencies and but you made a very
telling statement there which is you
said all of them people have tried to
make bitcoin variants and they all
failed all the other cryptocurrencies
are more like companies
and so they have someone centrally
involved and um so why are people like
elon musk for example interested in
coins like it's the deutsche dogecoin is
that do only good every day coin is that
it and it was sort of a parody coin to
begin with as far as i my limited
understanding enables me to so
bitcoin isn't that usable that's a
problem why
why shouldn't we just be skeptical of
cryptocurrency as such given the
multiplicity of cryptocurrencies so
yeah so in terms of the usability i
think um
the limit the reason that you don't use
bitcoin currently to buy things from
your shop is not the technological use
issue it's simply the liquidity issue
it's the fact that for the vast majority
of people right now uh well overall the
money balances over the world
uh bitcoin constitutes somewhere in the
range of one percent of the world's
money balances so the odds that you are
going to be trading with somebody
who has enough bitcoin that they are
willing to take the other end of the
trade you know let's say you want to buy
a assembly
and they're willing to
lose some to accept some extra bitcoin
to add it onto their balance sheet is
very low because most people have zero
bitcoin and most people haven't heard of
bitcoin so it's still very early so
um the the that problem is um
is in my mind it's just an issue of
liquidity it's not an issue of interface
or user you know you don't know how your
refrigerator works your car a lot of
machines we have no idea how they work
but you know you know how to operate
them
and so bitcoin is like that and we saw
in el salvador you know now
um
mcdonald's and starbucks are accepting
bitcoin it's just there is a very easy
way in in el salvador in el salvador
yeah why why
so it was announced as a national
currency as a legal tender um in
salvador in fact you know we're
recording just one day after that law
went into effect so now el salvador has
two official currencies the us dollar
and bitcoin they used to run on why did
they do that
um it's an interesting move from the
president of el salvador i think
yeah it's a radical move it's amazing i
can't believe it
yeah one one motivation is that a lot of
el salvadorians send remittances back to
their country
and there's a lot of money in that so
they could save with it on bitcoin right
so that's a place where bitcoin could
really
would could really get wide usage is a
replacement for things like western
union that's a big deal given how much
money passes from first world countries
to third world countries it's a huge
issue
yes and i think you know still over time
i still think you know it's it's it's um
it's it's going to be a while until the
whole world can move on to a bitcoin
based economy because it's just you know
you don't
there's a hundred trillion dollars of
money out there in the world we're not
going to bitcoin can't eat all of that
in a weekend no but it's stunning that
it's even one percent of that i mean
that's unbelievable that's a huge
percentage of it it's it's a huge
percentage because you know the the vast
majority of that the vast majority of
currencies are under one percent bitcoin
is bigger than the vast majority of
currencies there's only like maybe five
or six currencies that are bigger than
bitcoin the big ones you know and then
all the other ones are just tiny little
fractions next to it
so it's astonishing that we've gotten so
far but i think uh you know in terms of
the interface issue it's uh
let me just put it this way all of the
solutions that you currently use for
paying with your fiat can be adapted for
bitcoin you know visa could add you know
visa already provides the us dollar and
the canadian dollar in the euro and 160
currencies from all over the world they
can add 161 and then you'll be able to
pay with bitcoin okay so you think
that's a threshold issue enough users
that'll just start to happen the market
will drive that okay
and we have the bitcoin native solutions
as well
okay now the issue of the other
cryptocurrencies the other
cryptocurrencies i think in my mind they
are dilutive of each other but they are
not dilutive of bitcoin because um
bitcoin continues to grow very rapidly
and i think um
you know the other cryptocurrencies
their value proposition rests on some
kind of special feature that they
provide none of them is really trying to
compete with bitcoin on being this
neutral money neutral protocol
none of them can claim in any kind of
serious sense to be uh doing that so
okay so so let me ask you about that so
so does that mean that
bitcoin is addressing
the issue of the store of value the
long-term permanent store of value
decentralized
in the most philosophically
uh profound possible manner in some
sense these other cryptocurrencies they
have other features but that's not the
problem they're
essentially trying to address
yes so they're in a different category
yeah all the currencies that try to
market themselves as a competitor to
bitcoin in this field have sunk without
a trace and the ones that have uh stuck
around have
introduced a whole bunch of buzzwords
about other things that they supposed to
be doing and like what like what what
what what's what's been popular
um
so there's all kinds of things like you
know smart contracts and uh
decentralized finance
honestly if you ask me like uh
none of that stuff has shown any uh sign
of being anything more than a uh
basically uh
a pump and dump scheme wherein you know
people come in and they buy the token
there's a story like there's a story
about how this thing is going to be used
for you know there was talk about uh
betting markets and uh smart contracts
and uh real estate on the blockchain and
um
and now they're putting pictures on the
blockchain and they're selling art on
the blockchain and all these fads come
and go
but um ultimately
none of them needs its own monetary
system in order for it to function
and i think the
the accurate interpretation here is that
these things are just monetary systems
that have a side story that they're
selling you about what their application
is but nobody's really buying them in
order to buy these applications because
they don't really perform
um anything that
bitcoin cannot do or that you know any
kind of
real world use case it's just people are
buying these currencies um and they're
speculating on the price and the value
of all of these currencies is going up
because you know we're starting from a
very small level however i think you
know the distinction is that in the long
run
these currencies need to continue to
invent new stories and continue to
invent new narratives to continue to
drive more attention to them
um but whatever story you invent in your
currency you know there will be other
currencies that will come and um
invest
in you know promoting this in a better
way so i think they are dilutive for
each other because whatever value
proposition you have you know let's say
our
blockchain network does the best smart
contracts well what's stopping somebody
else from copying that there's nothing
that you can't copy about it they can
just move the same thing and start
another network that does it um right
which is essentially the equivalent of
printing money it's the electronic
equivalent of printing money in that
currency exactly and so
i think you know maybe this speculative
game won't run long but
ultimately altcoins are easy money
because they individually you can
increase their supply there's a group of
people that can sit down and change the
money supply for all of these coins and
that's the case with you know the second
biggest uh currency after bitcoin they
they've changed their monetary policy
six times maybe since creation and uh
and that's which platform
ethereum ethereum right right and yeah
yeah so they've changed the monetary
supply so they could change it in any
case and you know uh if anything tells
us that there's always reasons why you
want to print money so there will come
times in which you're going to need to
print money and there will be pressure
and they did go through a case where you
know somebody hacked um their
somebody hacked one of their
contracts took a lot of money out of it
from the people that were pretty
influential in it and they did roll it
back they effectively um essentially ran
an admin move where they froze
everybody's account well not exactly
froze but they reversed the transactions
in order to secure their own they reset
the day
exactly exactly so that's that's you
know that's that's the best competitor
when it comes to bitcoin so none of them
can really establish the scarcity so for
me in the long run i would not recommend
i i don't feel comfortable recommending
any of this of course you could make uh
money in the short run there's a lot of
fluctuation but in the long run you know
these things continue to make more and
the supply contains increase and you
need and you need a base of people to
continue to hold them for the long run
in order for the value to stay in them
and i don't see
any compelling narrative for people to
want to store serious value in
these currencies in the long run and i
don't see that they could trust it
because of the fact that it can be
increased and i think it
you know it individually can be
increased but collectively all of them
you know you're constantly making new
currencies that trading on this novelty
so the market for novelty you know the
demand for novelty even if it's larger
than the demand for the store of value
of bitcoin is getting dissipated at the
all the extra inflation of all these
novelty coins that are being added every
year
um
and you know i i don't pay much
attention to this world because in my
mind
i've paid enough attention and
seen the patterns which is that it's you
know these stories are generally there
to uh
sell the story of the uh currency that
exists there but i think bitcoin is
really all you need bitcoin is the one
that i that i can trust will be there in
10 years in 15 and 20 and 50. so let me
ask you about one more thing i want to i
want you to talk about your online
learning platform and why you built that
why you're doing that what you think the
implications are what you offer people
what that means for the future of
education let's say why you aren't in
the traditional university system i know
that's a lot but i do really want to
hear what you have to say about it
um i was at the traditional university
system but um you know the internet
changes everything and um
towards the time when i uh started
learning about bitcoin it really changed
the way that i think about the world and
in
gave me an understanding of the power of
technology
and the power of uh innovation and the
power of the internet and
i started realizing just the limitation
of the physical university model which
is you're stuck in a small classroom
with students many of them are there
just because they want the credentials
not for the actual learning
and the economics of it are uh not very
good because you know the students pay a
lot of money and this professors don't
get paid a lot of money and then a lot
of money gets lost in the middle in the
gigantic bureaucracy which expands way
faster than the faculty and and
continually undermines the power of the
faculty with the faculty's own uh what
would you call they're concentrating on
the research and they're politically
naive and they get they get their power
gets inflated away to a tremendous
degree every year
i warned my colleagues about this sort
of thing
continually when i was a faculty member
and
they never paid attention i said you
you're you just have no idea what you're
giving away and well okay so
so and i you know i've had the same
experience as you i think i mean i was
i've had a lot of health problems
recently but i was thinking about going
back to the university i've resigned
from the university of toronto my my
original position i'm a professor
emeritus now
but i thought if i'm well enough to go
back to the university and teach
i'm well enough to teach on the net
if i teach on the net i can talk to
people like you every day
i never have to teach the same course
twice
i can learn while i'm teaching
and i can teach to like five hundred
thousand to a million people continually
so why in the world with no
administrative overhead whatsoever
direct to consumer
exactly so
that was that was really it and um for
me i think the most frustrating part of
academia is uh the the uh peer-reviewed
journal nonsense it's just an enormously
frustrating ritual where you that's no
no the grant the grant writing system is
worse
yeah well i'm in my defense i never went
that far i could never get myself to
wrap well you know the typical the
typical researcher in the united states
in particular you get big grants in the
us but they're impossible to get whereas
in canada you get small grants and if
you do a grant proposal properly you
probably get a grant small but in the
states the typical scientist
spends 40 percent of his or her time
writing grant proposals
and that that is not what they're good
at like that's not the same as being an
entrepreneurial and researcher it isn't
the same skill set at all yeah it's it's
a so it's a and then you don't get the
grants yeah and in particular teaching
is massively massively undervalued in
the modern university you know your
university hires you mostly
for how many publications you can get no
no no no no now it hires you mostly for
you the quality of your diversity
statement
now i'm not kidding i'm not kidding this
is really happening in california
cardinal but not also not research now
it's literally the case that in the uc
systems
the diversity statement which is just
something that that crept in say five
six years ago you have to provide a
diversity statement along with your
research statement that has more weight
with regards to the hiring procedure
then the research
history
and teaching well it's like who cares
about the damn undergraduates right so
yeah yeah fiat education is another
chapter in the fiat standard where you
know i take my experience from the
university world where essentially again
it's the same story the financing
doesn't come from the customers for the
students whether it's at the university
or school level it comes from above and
so the bureaucracy is optimized for
sucking more money from above
and it essentially uses the students as
the props to do that in fact you know
universities get a lot of money uh a lot
more money from
governments
directly or indirectly you know
government subsidize the loans for the
students so even student money is
effectively government money and so um
they're
that they're optimizing focusing on
kissing the hand that feeds them and
that's why the university is becoming so
politicized it's also part of fiat
disease
it's
it's not the case when uh it's not how
universities functioned under the gold
standard they were at far more integrity
because the money had integrity and so
the only way that you could get your
university to have money was you know to
teach people useful things so that they
would be happy and they would tell their
friends to go to that university and
they would donate money but this kind of
cycle is breaking now that's why we see
so many
um god even the economist even the
economist miracle of miracles has
published
articles in the last month pointing out
that the politicization of the
university campus which is something
that i've been observing for like 20
years and have been warning people about
is having these massive downstream
consequences throughout society
it's like and that's definitely the case
and so why is that politicization
occurring
so exactly and so for me you know it was
i wanted to just um i it was like you
know bitcoin like uber it's like
sidestep the entire
monster
and figure out what it is what is the
essence of what it is that i'm good at i
like to teach i enjoy teaching so i'm
going to build a website and i'm going
to you know i i the the writing the
bitcoin standard was uh what allowed me
the courage to take this move and i i i
regret not doing it earlier um but
once i had a
little bit of a global audience that i
could follow you know it was i could
teach many more students that i could
teach in a physical classroom
where much more interested
and you know this is this is what i
learned from austrian economics you want
to follow the place where you're able to
create more value that's what you need
to follow so people seem to like what i
was doing online and so i thought i'm
going to try and figure it out so uh how
long has this been yeah how long has it
been in operation
is that safetying.com
safeidean.com yes two years now i've had
it running for uh to actually yeah just
turned two years uh
ah a couple of weeks ago i didn't make a
big deal well congratulations so so so
tell me tell me like um
what size audience are you serving how
is it growing what have you learned how
are you generating revenue
the first couple of years i've focused
on building rather than um getting a
bigger audience i've made it a little
bit more
it's it's mainly focused on you know my
audience on twitter they're the ones who
sign up i haven't promoted it widely i
haven't done any advertisement i haven't
raised funds i've been focused for the
first couple of years on just
learning um how to do the courses online
and to putting the courses online and
focusing on the topic itself you know
how to make an actual online course
rather than marketing this and growing
it and on also writing my two books so
it's like the platform for me to um
intellectually stimulate myself and
discuss things with students as i write
the book it was enormously valuable for
me to writing the book and it's you know
i remember in the university the
teaching process is something that gives
you the ideas for writing and i wanted
to make sure that i had that as i left
the university i didn't want to just
write i wanted to have seminars where i
discuss things so i could i have two
live seminars every week with uh members
of safeindeen.com uh twice a week we get
together and we discuss um
my books my work my courses uh bitcoin
in general austrian economics and all
kinds of other issues
and so now now it's a little bit
it's being done on a smaller scale as i
was focusing on the courses in the books
the plan is you know starting next year
i'm going to start
hopefully expanding the operation as i
have my books completed and my next two
books i'm also writing an economics
textbook as well
so you know the the next problem to
solve for the decentralization of
education i've been thinking about this
for a long time as
as
it's possible to learn more and more
online
is accreditation is where all the value
is all of it and i've talked to many
wise academics like seriously wise
academics who know perfectly well that
there's almost zero
financial utility in the knowledge that
universities are dispensing to students
it's not zero but it's low but there's
tremendous residual value in the
accreditation
so the next big revolution is going to
be the decentralization
hopefully the decentralization of
accreditation
so that there's a
there's a there's a way of providing
verifiable accreditation so i've been
thinking about that so you to some
degree so you can imagine something like
a set of exams
where only 10 percent of the people who
take them pass or maybe it's 20 percent
that's bronze 10 percent that's silver 5
that's gold you can retake the exams
multiple times
but you keep it scarce
and so
the accreditation there's tremendous
economic value in the decentralization
of educational accreditation
because the content is going to be
provided right by people like you
perhaps by people like me that's going
to just keep happening and that's going
to find its own market
so
well so i don't know how that problem
might be solved but
yeah the way that i solved it in my
first two years was that i just told
people you know um i'm gonna only give
knowledge i'm not gonna
do anything
right right right
yeah that that's that's how you that's a
reasonable approach too you know and and
and it sort of relies on your trust in
the students themselves in some sense
right you don't have to sit through this
you're not going to get anything out of
it except the knowledge
that's a reasonable approach and maybe
it's the right one it's just
for those who wish to educate to do so
and to let the chips fall where they're
going to fall
and also i think you know there is there
are some downsides to testing that you
have to kind of formulate the education
in a way that is uh aminable for testing
and that can
corrupt the system
exactly
it's like predicting the future
right it's the same problem it's like
which part of the knowledge that you've
learned is relevant
and can we form and so there's the
hypothesis that we can formalize that
now you know you might be able to do it
in some ways by
because maybe you can test something
like uh literate literacy
right because that's a that's a broad
scale skill that's
you useful across multiple domains and
so maybe there's a role there for
for
testing to specify level of skill
but it gets much more difficult in other
areas so that's that's partly why the
the accreditation problem is real tough
one to solve to do it properly
i don't know i i go back and forth on
whether accreditation really is such a
big deal or whether it's going whether
the whole issue of accreditation is
going to be devalued over time because
yes yeah
in a sense i can see how it was valuable
in the pre-internet world where you know
going to a university and spending four
years taking courses with the experts on
a topic next to a physical library that
actually contained the books on the
topic
was
basically the only way that you could
establish confidence in the topic
and getting a degree that you've ticked
all the boxes was a very reliable signal
that you did do that
but now
you know the knowledge is all out there
and
[Music]
the people looking to hire you are
becoming increasingly
practical increasingly specialized about
what they're looking for you know
it's not that big of a deal whether you
have a degree in all those um
fascinating topics that you learned
about
um you know can you build a mousetrap
that catches much right exactly have you
so that might mean that the
accreditation problem is actually
downloaded to the people who consume the
students so to speak
right
and that that's the people who are doing
the hiring i mean the hiring people have
a tough job and they were using
accreditation as a shortcut to doing
their job properly relying on the
institutional validity of the
universities to select the proper
students and they were
universities were basically doing that
on the basis of it of uh
making it difficult to get into the
universities and and by proxy selecting
people who had high levels of of g fluid
intelligence
so
basically
yeah
and it's it's becoming less and less
valuable as a signal as knowledge
becomes everywhere it becomes available
everywhere you don't need to go to a
physical library and you don't need to
be next to the professor you can
download the lectures online and you can
discuss things with students online you
can recreate the entire university
experience online basically now
is it as fun as going onto a campus well
no but you know when you think about the
difference in costs you could learn an
entire undergraduate degree for a couple
hundred bucks online
you know think about all the extra money
that you save and all the extra time
that you save i don't think about how
much fun you could have with that
and that's when it becomes a fair
comparison i think
[Music]
well look that was great i learned a
tremendous amount you really made me
think uh he cleared up a lot of the
questions i had about cryptocurrency and
about uh about bitcoin i understand how
it functions better some of it was
absolutely fascinating like that idea
that you can monetize energy production
in in
in areas that wouldn't be able to ship
the electricity to market that's that's
absolutely mind-boggling it'll take me
like five years to think that through
it's so s and it seems to completely
contradict the idea that bitcoin is a
waste of of of the world's resources
right it's it's it's it's a complete
opposite if that if this monetization
idea is actually true
so that's really really really
interesting
so
yeah that was great i'd like to talk to
you again at some point so um
we'll see how people respond to this and
what sort of questions they have and
what sort of things they might like us
to discuss but uh i really enjoyed the
conversation so thanks a lot for for all
that and good luck with your book
your new book so that new book so
everyone remembers the two books are um
the bitcoin standard and the fiat
standard and my
you're going to learn a lot by reading
those books an awful lot i learned a lot
about the austrian school of economics
too and about its fundamental
philosophical differences and that was
really useful to me as well so lots of
lots of pieces fell into place the sign
of a good conversation when that happens
so
thank you thank you very much it was an
absolute pleasure as well i enjoyed
talking to you very much and i hope you
do it again
[Music]
you